and act prejudicial to the safety or
interests of the state
contrary to section 11c of the official
Secrets Act 1911.
you pleaded guilty to those offenses on
the 4th of November last year
but did so on a basis which was
unacceptable to the prosecution
and which had I accepted it would have
made a significant difference to your
sentence
therefore I held a hearing earlier this
week to determine the proper basis on
which to sentence you
you gave evidence at that hearing
I rejected your basis of plea and
determined that you should be sentenced
in line with the prosecution case
I have already given a full judgment
outlining my reasons for reaching that
conclusion
I will not repeat those reasons now but
we'll briefly set out the facts of the
offenses as I have found them to be
you as a British citizen were employed
in the British Embassy in Berlin as a
security guard from 2016 until the time
of your arrest in 2021
in that time if not before
you developed decidedly anti-british and
anti-western feelings
the people with whom you worked would
hear you criticizing this country and
your then country of residence Germany
they formed the impression that you were
more sympathetic to Russia and in
particular to uh General President Putin
you yourself accepted in evidence that
at one stage during your employment at
the embassy you were supportive of the
russian-backed rebels in the dombas
region of the Ukraine who wanted to
return to Russian rule
I have already found as a fact that
these feelings were the direct cause of
your offending
against that background in 2018
you started to collect information from
the British Embassy to which you were
not entitled
you continued to do this until your
arrest in 2021
you did it by stealth
using the opportunities provided to you
by your employment
to visit various offices in the embassy
at night when others had gone home and
take photographs of classified documents
on your telephone or camera
a number of these documents were clearly
marked as Secret
others were of a lower classification
but was still obviously not the
dissemination beyond the embassy
of the clearly secret documents one was
a sensitive report addressed to the then
prime minister of this country Boris
Johnson sent to him by members of his
cabinet
some of the documents of a lower
classification revealed the names
photographs and personal details of
Embassy staff
you found some of these documents on
desks or displayed in areas of the
embassy not open to the public
others you removed from private draws in
desks in order that you might copy them
you were fully aware that you should not
have copied any of these documents
and were equally aware that were these
documents to get into the wrong hands
they might harm British interests or
pose a threat to the safety of people
working at the embassy
these activities are reflected in counts
three and four on the indictment
I am mindful that the indictment period
only runs from April 2020
but I am sure that you collected
material in 2018 and 2019 with a view to
damaging British interests
I can only sentence you for your
activities within the indictment period
but when I assess your culpability for
events in 2020 and 2021
I do so against the background that your
subversive activities have begun two
years before the indictment period
commenced
having taken copies of these documents
you then downloaded them from your phone
or camera onto your personal computer or
other electronic storage devices
you took care to store some documents in
a way which made it less likely that
they would be found by someone who
casually examined them
for example you put some of the
photograph documents containing personal
details of Embassy staff into a file the
name of which suggested that it
contained nothing but holiday
photographs
you copied a significant amount of
material over the years
the material has been outlined in the
prosecution opening
and put into a useful table by your
representatives which was presented to
me in the course of mitigation
I do not need to rehearse again the
detail of that material
I need only record that it was
voluminous and obviously gathered on a
number of dates and not all at one time
in 2020 you also took a number of videos
of those areas of the embassy into which
the public have no right of access
these videos were carefully and
methodically filmed
they contained a considerable amount of
information which would be and you knew
would be useful to a hostile foreign
power
I am sure that you took those videos
with that in mind
and that this video footage was always
designed to be provided to the Russians
you film the name plates on the doors of
offices
personal information about the office's
occupants which was on display in the
rooms
and any potentially useful documents
left on a Surface in the room or you
found put away in a desk
you would often include footage of the
view from the window of the office
this can only have been so that anyone
who viewed the footage could have
pinpointed where in the embassy building
any particular room could be located
this activity is reflected in count two
you started to pass on this information
to the Russians in May 2020
in that month you wrote anonymously to
General sirov a military attache at the
Russian Embassy
you're enclosed with your letter A
booklet you had obtained from the
British Embassy which set out the names
of people working there
along with some contact details for them
and a description of the roles they
performed within the embassy
in that letter you promised that more
information would be forthcoming
the other specific example of you
passing on information
was a letter you wrote to General major
shipcraft another military attache at
the Russian Embassy in November 2020
in that letter
you provided an update on people newly
arrived to work in the organization
you also Pastor him photographs of
Embassy staff
which you had deliberately annotated
with personal details of the people
depicted in them
you put those people at maximum Risk by
so doing
it is not possible for me to determine
how many more times you made contact
with someone in the Russian Embassy and
passed on material to them
there is no direct evidence of what
other contacts took place
but for the reasons I have given in my
previous judgment
I am sure that at some stage in 2020 you
established regular contact with someone
at the Russian Embassy
and that this contact was a conduit
through which material illegally
obtained by you was passed on
the sole count on the indictment
concerning the onward provision of
material to the Russians is count one
that is the count that relates to your
correspondence with General major
shootcraft
there is no count on the indictment
relating to your other contacts
however when I pass sentence on count
one
I can take into account
that this was not a one-off action
but an offense committed against the
background that you had previously
contacted General Cyril and provided him
with information
and that is about the time of the
contacting count one you established a
contact at the Russian Embassy and
passed more information to Russia by
those means
you were paid by Russia for your
treachery
there is unsurprisingly no documentation
which records the amounts you were paid
I accept that there is no evidence that
the payments amounted to life-changing
sums of money
but it was enough
to enable you to save up 800 Euros by
the time of your arrest
and to exist without making significant
withdrawals on your bank account
which have previously been necessary for
you to meet your living expenses
I regard these payments as a significant
factor in increasing your culpability
for your actions
your duplicity went on until the time of
your arrest
by August 2021 unbeknown to you
the British authorities suspected you of
being involved in the provision of
information to Russia
this resulted in what might be termed a
sting operation being carried out
a British agent who was not known to you
and you were told was called Dimitri
met one of the embassy staff in your
presence
in circumstances suggesting that they
were a Russian seeking to pass
classified documents to the British
authorities
you took the opportunity presented to
you by this situation to collect more
information which would have assisted
Russia and damaged British interests
when you were asked by Dimitri to
photocopy a document in Russian which
you took to be classified
you took an extra copy for yourself
which you kept
this is count five
when the employee of the embassy gave
the man calling himself Dimitri a SIM
card or stensibly for him to make
contact with the British when he had
more information to give
you kept the packaging from that SIM
card rather than throw it away as you
were asked to do
this is count six
finally over two days using your mobile
telephone
you filmed the embassy's CCTV footage of
Dimitri's visit
in doing so you focused on Dimitri's
face so that it could be clearly seen
this conduct is represented by count
seven and eight on the indictment
you were effectively led into believing
that Dimitri was a traitor to Russia who
was offering information to the United
Kingdom
I am sure that you collected together
the document
the SIM card packaging and the images
from the CCTV
with a view to passing them on to
Russian authorities
had Dimitri been a genuine visitor to
the British Embassy
and therefore a Russian genuinely trying
to pass secrets to the British
it is impossible to know what would have
been the consequences for him of having
his treachery to Russia exposed in this
way by you
it is self-evident that this case
demands an immediate prison sentence
in those circumstances no pre-sentence
report could help me and none has been
obtained or asked for
there is no specific offense guideline
to assist me in fixing the appropriate
length of sentence
I therefore use the sentence in
council's general guideline
pursuant to that guideline I must fix
sentence by weighing up both your
culpability and the harm done by your
behavior
in making those judgments
I must have regard to any guidance given
by the court of appeal Criminal Division
I have been helpfully referred to a
selection of relevant authorities
course each case turns on its facts
but I glean a number of guiding
principles from those authorities
which I intend to employ in your case
in particular
it is clear that there is a strong and
recognized public interest in protecting
secret information
sentences must reflect the public lack
of Tolerance towards those who do not
respect this
the sentence ought to contain an element
of deterrence to others who might be
tempted to act in this way in the future
and when assessing harm I should
consider harm actually caused harm
intended
and any harm which was a foreseeable
consequence of your actions
I must of course always have in mind the
statutory aims of sentencing of which in
my judgment punishment is the most
important in a case such as this
I assess your culpability as high
you were a security guard at the embassy
it is not a senior position
but it is one which imposed on you a
high level of trust and responsibility
it was your job to ensure that the
embassy was Secure and its staff safe
you had access to restricted areas of
the building at times when nobody else
was likely to be there
when you did what you did it was the
most obvious breach of the trust placed
in you
in addition I am sure that you committed
these crimes intending to assist Russia
a state which at that time as now was
regarded as unfriendly to the United
Kingdom
your motive in assisting them was to
damage British interests
although you did not start to pass
material to the Russians until 2020
I am sure that you gathered all of this
material with a view to harming British
interests in some way
your unlawful Behavior was persistent
and to an extent sophisticated
you copied documents of many types and
carefully stored them
you took videos of the embassy in a way
which would have been of maximum
assistance to the Russians
you did as much as you could to ensure
that Dimitri's identity could be
revealed
as I have already noted your level of
culpability is increased still further
by the fact that you were receiving
money for your criminal conduct
it is hard to say what harm was actually
caused by your actions
harm could only accurately be measured
if one knew for certain how much
information you had actually passed on
which is unascertainable
how much was novel to the Russians and
how much known to them already
and how far they were able and willing
to use it
as I remarked yesterday the Russian
authorities are hardly likely to assist
this court in answering those questions
however to assist me I have been
provided with a number of statements
from British officials which address the
level of harm you caused
in taking out of the embassy personal
details relating to its staff
you put all of those staff at increased
risk of harm
they had to be told that their security
had been compromised in this way
and the level of danger caused by your
actions then had to be managed
it is called some of the people involved
and their families understandable
anxiety and distress
the embassy has had to undertake an
overhaul of its processes and procedures
to ensure that it does not remain
compromised
in purely financial terms this has cost
the taxpayers of this country eight
hundred and twenty thousand pounds so
far
the extraction of documents relating to
trade and international relations had in
this case as in every case of this type
the potential to reduce the
effectiveness of future British
negotiations
or reduce the level of trust put in this
country by its allies
I assess the level of harm in your case
to be high but not at the highest
it is high because of the volume of
material you took from the embassy
the personal details it contained
on the period of time over which you did
it
in addition the material you obtained
was deliberately passed on to an
unfriendly foreign power
there have been tangible and
ascertainable harms caused by your
activities
and there exists the foreseeable
possibility that the Damage Done could
extend beyond that which is obvious to
date
I say that it is not of the highest
because you did not for example obtain
or reveal top-level military Secrets or
details of British armaments which would
have lifted this case into the very
highest category
I have decided that it would be
appropriate to pass on you concurrent
terms for each offense relating to the
obtaining of the documentation and
images from the embassy
these all form part of the same cause of
conduct
I include in that the sentences relating
to counts five to eight the counts
relating to the Man known as Dimitri
although these counts arose from a sting
operation
they were as far as you were concerned a
continuation of your activities of
gathering information which might be of
use to Russia and detrimental to the
United Kingdom
the sentence on each of those counts
will reflect your overall culpability
for this aspect of your behavior
on all of the count save count one I
adopt a starting point for sentence
after trial of nine years
count one which concerns the supplying
documents to the Russian authorities
represents a further and separate if
related course of conduct
which ought properly to attract a
consecutive sentence
the sentencing authorities make clear
that consecutive sentence in cases such
as this are merited where a single
course of conduct is particularly
protracted
or where the behavior of a defendant is
rightly to be regarded as more than one
single course of conduct
the proper starting point for sentence
on discount after trial had it stood
alone would in my judgment have been one
of ten years
however I must reflect in my sentence
that this count relates directly to some
of the documentation already covered by
count two to eight
to that end I reduce my starting point
after trial on count 1 to 7 years
the factors which in other circumstances
I would have found aggravated the
offending your financial benefit from
doing what you did
the abuse of trust and the fact that
people were put at risk by your actions
have all already been taken into account
in fixing the starting points for your
sentence and I do not count them again
your mitigation lies solely in your
previous good character
the credit for that must be limited as
the offending here was so extensive and
so serious
I reject any suggestion that you are
remorseful for your actions
your regrets are no more than self-pity
when any expression of remorse was
tested during the mutant hearing
you concentrated on the effects that
you're offending had on yourself your
wife and your parents
when asked about the potentially
catastrophic consequences for others
you repeatedly suggested that these were
non-existent or negligible as you only
provided to the Russians information
which they already had available to them
had you been truly remorseful you would
not have lied on oath to me in that
hearing as you did
neither do I intend to reduce your
sentence significantly for any mental
health difficulties you may have
there is no medical evidence before me
on which to judge how serious they were
at the time of your offending or are now
I have already recorded my view that I
see no logical causal link between
depression and a decision to betray your
country
I cannot reduce your sentence
significantly based simply on your
self-reporting symptoms and anecdotal
observations of others without expert
evidence to guide me as to the true
effect this has had on you
foreign
I was further asked in mitigation to
temper your sentence by reference to the
fact that you were under suspicion of
passing secrets to the Russians from
late 2020 or early 2021.
and committed some of this offending
while under that suspicion
I declined to do so
I have rightly not been told of the way
in which any investigation into your
conduct was pursued save in so far as
directly relevant to the issues in this
case
whatever the reasons for the authorities
to act as they did and keep you imposed
it was you who made the decision to
continue to offend and you who must
accept full blame for that
overall your limited mitigation allows
me to reduce your sentence by one year
the total figure so far therefore is one
of 15 years
you will get credit for your guilty plea
I have afforded I would have afforded
you 25 credit had you not pleaded guilty
on a false basis which necessitated a
Newton hearing
I arrive at the figure of 25 percent
because you pleaded guilty when first
arraigned
but did so having served a defense
statement suggesting that you were not
guilty
your arraignment was delayed a number of
times to give you an opportunity to
consider your position
in those circumstances a full reduction
of one-third would not be appropriate
however the sentencing Council guideline
on credit for guilty plea
suggests that a reduction of 50 percent
in the level of credit is appropriate
where a defendant contests and loses a
Newton hearing
therefore I will afford you
approximately 12 and a half percent
credit for your guilty pleas
this reduces your overall sentence to
One of 13 years and two months
that will be made up of a sentence of
six years and two months on count one
and a consecutive term of seven years on
all other counts
finally in arriving at your sentence I
apply the sentencing Council guideline
on totality
and consider whether this total sentence
is just unproportionate to reflect your
overall criminality
in my judgment it is
it reflects your culpability and the
harm done
and is a proportionate reflection of
your serious conduct bearing in mind the
need for deterrence and Punishment in
cases such as this
in reaching that conclusion I have had
regard to sentences passed in other
cases of this type in the past
significantly longer sentences than this
have been reserved for offenders such as
George Blake whose treachery was in my
judgment of a much greater magnitude
than yours
significantly shorter sentences have
been reserved for people whose activity
was in my judgment more limited than
your own
such as in the authorities referred to
me of James and Finch
Mr Smith stand up
on count one of this indictment I
sentence you to a term of six years two
months imprisonment
on count two to eight I sentenced you to
concurrent terms of seven years
but those terms will be served
consecutively to your sentence on count
one
making a total term of 13 years two
months
the time you have served in custody
reparable to these offenses will count
towards your sentence
that will include both the time spent on
remand in this country
and the 10 days I certify you spent in
custody in Germany awaiting extradition
if you serve your sentence in the United
Kingdom you will be released after you
have served half of that sentence you
will then be on license until the expiry
of the total term
if you breach the terms of your license
you can be returned to serve the
remainder of your sentence in custody
if you serve your sentence in Germany
their rules on early release will apply
to you
it is not for me to decide where your
sentence will be served
the surcharge will apply in this case in
the usual amount
I make no orders for confiscation or
destruction of your computer and other
equipment used in this offending as it
is in Germany
if you do not voluntarily relinquish
your rights in it it will be for the
German courts to consider any further
applications
been taken down